I'm john nice to see you all. How many of
you watched CNN on election night. So you
know, my friend, this is my friend, we call
her magic or him. Um, And 2008 we introduced
the Magic Wall and it has literally revolutionized
television now. If you turn on the television,
many of you are too young to understand that
the progression of the change, but you cannot
watch the show, whether it's a sports show,
whether it's a political show, whether it's
a new show, these things show up everywhere.
Uh, now, uh, and uh, to my point about the
people you don't know and you don't see, don't
get enough credit. We have two of the members
of our, um, our Magic wall team, our digital
team, new media. We call them back here Caroline
and billy. Maybe they'll come out. Maybe they
won't. Billy roots from michigan. Is that
okay on the George Washington campus? Billy's
big michigan. Um, so I'm gonna spend eight
or 10 minutes here. I have a clock right here
just showing you how this works to show you
how, what a great information tool it is for
me on election nights on election nights,
it's live data. It's all coming in live. And
so I could be standing here talking to wolf
or jake or somebody and it's blue and then
it turns red, right? What does that mean?
It means more Republican votes came in and
the lead switched or vice versa. Tonight I
just want to use it to sort of set the stage
for what we expect. And uh, this is I've been
doing this for almost 40 years. This is the
most complicated midterm election of my lifetime
that goes back to the mid 19 eighties. Uh,
just because we have conflicting data points,
because the stakes are so enormous. Uh, just
because so much is at so many different pressures
and fractions at play everywhere. So I just
want to go through some basics first. This
is the senate, you all know, this is a 50
50 tie right now. So the democrats control
it because of the vice President, United States.
She breaks ties. Um, Republicans six months
ago thought they were going to get 50 to maybe
53 seats now, most of the smart people and
be aware of smart people. And I don't mean
to say they're not smart. It's just, it's
a really difficult year to figure out. But
most of the range of pickups now are plus
one or minus one for the democrats, meaning
the republicans either get to 51 or the democrats
maybe get to 52 or it stays 50 50. There are
a lot of smart people in both parties who
think it's going to stay 50 50 now. That's
based on today, 20 days out. But this is all
it takes right. So this is a republican health
seat in pennsylvania. The republican incumbent
is retiring. This race gets a lot of attention.
The Democratic candidate for lieutenant governor,
interesting guy, not a traditional politics,
had a stroke. In addition to that back late
in the primary. So john Fetterman gets a lot
of attention? So does dr Oz, because he's
a celebrity tv doctor, some people like that,
some people don't trump, endorsed him. That
was an issue in the republican primary. So,
this is a fascinating race. But if you think
about it from the math perspective, I do math
on election night, democrats have 50 what
they would love to do, especially early on,
right? You go east to west as polls closed
is pick one up because you might lose one
somewhere. So if you can do this and pick
one up, right, what happens then let me come
back to here and come on out, then you're
at 51 right? So if the democrats can boost
their numbers somehow in the east, as we go
west, because democrats are very nervous about
this one out in Nevada, democrats are increasingly
nervous in Nevada and they're worried this
might happen out there. And so that's the
chess game that's gonna play out on election
night. This is all hypothetical, I don't know
what's going to happen on election night,
I never do. That's the magic of it. But this
is so if the democrats, you're thinking, can
we pick that up, right? That's why the democrats,
there was a debate last night in florida,
there's a surprisingly competitive race in
north Carolina, democrats are thinking, can,
you know, lightning strike somewhere, Can
we have a little magic and get a pick up of
one of the ones that when you come back to
where we actually are right now, Can you pick
up one of these reds right? Because you might
lose some blues, You could lose Georgia, you
could lose Nevada, you might lose Arizona
colorado has become very competitive for the
democrats. So the chess game is early in the
night, which party has the advantage? And
then we go from there for those of you who
remember 2020 I would just say be prepared.
I hope it's not election week in America again,
but be prepared for election days in America
Again, I want to get to a couple of questions
before I bring out my colleagues and I don't
want to keep them waiting too long because
they're really great and they're really smart
and they can really help us go through this.
But I just want to go through a few, a few
of the questions to use the magic wall. Michael
asked this question. Which congressional district
should we look at? You know, two see any indication
of the night. That's a great question. It's
a great question. And it's what I have to
think about as I prepare for election night.
So let's look at look at it this way for the
house battle of control. This is where we
are right now. You see these yellow districts,
These are the districts we've determined with
the help of Inside Elections as a newsletter
written by a great smart journalist, Nathan
Gonzales. These are what we view as the competitive
districts. Some of them are true to itself.
Those are the yellow ones. Then we have other
districts. They're tilting Democratic or they're
tilting republican, but they're close enough.
They're close enough in the districts are
competitive enough in terms of registration
in terms of past performance in both presidential
and house elections that we want to keep a
close eye on. That's one way to look at it.
I just want to come out to another map and
look at it another way and come over here.
So you see again, if you're me on election
night, polls closed in the east, this is the
House right now you can do the math. You don't
have to be a rocket scientist here. Republicans
only need five in modern times in recent times.
Just go back Obama lost 63 seats in his first
midterm in 2010 trump lost 40 plus 42 43 in
the 2018 big Democratic blue wave there. So
if you're the democrats, you're nervous because
history says, can you keep republicans to
under five any in any year in a normal year,
then you add in inflation, you add in all
the other dynamics, the wind and the Democratic
face and it would be a pretty monumental defying
history for the democrats to hold the House.
This is one way we look at one of the things
we do on election night. As I showed you those
competitive districts on the other map. Here
they are on this map. So you can see them
who owns them right now, Who holds them right
now? You know, Red, that's a Republican seat.
I was in pennsylvania a few weeks ago. There
are a couple of big seats. Again, think about
early in the night, do we get clues about
what's happening? There are two Democratic
held seats right here. They're they're rematches
of 2020. Matt Cartwright is the Democratic
incumbent against the same Republican he read
against last time. Susan Wild, the Democratic
incumbent, she came into power in the blue
wave of 2018. She knows how hard it can be
in the President's first midterm, She benefited
from it when it was trump's first midterm.
She's got a wind in her face now that it's
biden's first midterm. This is another rematch
so early on. Can the democrats hold those
seats when the results come in? If they can
hold both of those seats? And this one out
here, this is the Connor Lam district out
in Western pennsylvania. Do you get a clue
early in the night that the democrats are
performing strongly or if these go red, these
are good, they're good Democratic candidates.
I don't take sides in politics. I just mean,
they're good candidates, they raise money,
they run good campaigns. They're doing what
it takes to be good on Election Day if they
lose, What does that tell us as we keep going
west. So that's one of the ways the information
in the map and in the wall helps me both from
a time zone perspective. It's just, it is
a it is a live amazing. I say it's fun and
people get people at home get mad at me because
if you're an invested democrat or you're an
invested Republican, you're biting your nails.
It's not fun for you. I get that. I get that
for me. This is fascinating as a student of
student of the game, who has no horse on the
track election nights are fun for me because
they're so challenging. This one is incredibly
challenging to get through it. Another great
question which races polls have been surprising
to you the most, especially this close to
election. I don't like to talk about polls
too much. Let's let the voters vote, but we
do learn some things when we come back to
the other map. One of the things I would say
is when you come back to the Senate. Um, it
has been to me and the dogs decision, we're
gonna talk a little bit about that. Some of
you have several smart questions about the
dog's decision. The Dobbs decision in late
june changed the dynamics. We were heading
towards what looked like a traditional presidents
doesn't matter their party go back through
history in recent times. The only exception
was George W Bush. The first election 2002
was the first election after 9 11 his party,
the country was still in crisis. His party
actually gained seats. But if you look at
this map right here, what has surprised me?
I am surprised that north Carolina is so close
in the sense that trump wanted big just two
years ago and cheri Beasley is in play, does
that mean she can win? I'm not saying she
can win. You know, not my job. The Georgia
races are incredibly close. A lot of people
thought herschel walker was a flawed candidate.
He's had character controversies in recent
days and weeks that I'm sure you're all aware
of and yet it has stayed locked in. That tells
us a lot about America right that some people
will stay in their partisan camp and democrats
due to that. I'm not picking on republicans
here. You just, you see that in races, people
just reflexively stay in their camp because
they want to this one early on was closer.
There was a big debate last night. It's moved
a little bit. There's states have D N A florida
used to be more of a toss up state ask al
gore. Um and uh um it has become more red
Ohio is in the same place. That's another
one to me. That is fascinating in the sense
that uh tim Ryan has kept it very close in
a state that trump won twice. You have a popular
Republican incumbent governor. So there are
some surprises out there that just tells me
we live in an age of volatility and we should
be prepared for volatility on election night.
At this point. I may get up once or twice
during the conversation, but let me bring
in my colleagues because they're awesome and
they can help go through your questions and
they make me smarter to have them around.
Nia malika Henderson is our senior political
analyst. Yeah, and she's rocking good kicks
abby Phillip, this anchor of inside Politics,
sunday, our senior political correspondent
and this is different and I think fun for
us, Rachel Smokin is here tonight. Rachel
is one of those people who you don't see on
television, right? You don't see on television.
Uh and in some ways makes her more important
in the sense she's a senior vice president
of global news for CNN and for CNN digital
worldwide, it's the biggest growth industry
of our business, those of us who are on television
uh like to think that, you know, like the
most important thing in the world to CNN um
more people get their news online uh and the
global reach of CNN that's why I work at CNN
the global reach of CNN is extraordinary and
Rachel is behind the scenes managing a team
of amazing reporters and editors and digital
people and visual people and she's helped
revolutionize CNN dot com when you go to it.
And it is it is a great piece of CNN success.
And the thing I hope, I hope you all access
and use quite frequently because it's it is
gold. It is just it is journalist of gold.
So let me get to the questions and we'll start
right here. Uh No, I don't actually at the
moment. Thank you though. This is the reason
I like them because you get they give you,
they give you know, they give you nothing
here. This is a good one here. This has come
up in several races as America undergoes the
demographic shift, how might the political
environment change to consider the interests
of latino voters, which party do you expect
will receive the majority of their votes going
into the future? Um It's our D. N. A. To not
go too far into the future. Right? We follow
the facts, not what we think. I'll tee it
up this way and then turn to Nia malika first.
Donald trump improved the Republican Party
standings among Latinos in 2020 particularly
among latino men, particularly in southern
florida. It's a different latino population
in southern florida than you might find in
the Virginia suburbs close to here. Then you
might find out in Nevada, but it is obviously
an incredibly fast growing piece of the american
population and a swing population in Nevada,
it's the big constituency, especially in clark
County in other places, even when it's only
three or 4% of the vote, if it's a 50 50 contest,
that's enough. Right? You win well among that
constituency, that's enough. So when you look
at the map this year or any particular race
this year, uh, That's the big question. Right?
Is that, is, was that an aberration in 2020
or a Republican starting to rebuild trust
with Latinos? Yes. And, and, and, and the
rebuild trust I think is exactly right. Because
if you go back many decades to Bush and Reagan
Republicans did fairly well with Latinos.
I grew up in South Carolina, the Latinos,
I didn't know in south Carolina growing up,
not a lot of them at that point. Most of those
folks were republicans. So in many ways it
is a sort of rebuilding of trust and a sort
of reversion to way to the way that Latinos
often voted. I think the latino vote will
matter greatly in a state like Nevada, uh,
in a state like texas obviously, and in Georgia,
which is increasingly diverse. I think the
electorate will essentially be like 60% white,
40% non white with Latinos and african americans
and asian americans as part of that 40%. But
listen, I think democrats in some ways have
taken Latinos for granted. Uh, and assuming
that some of donald trump's rhetoric would
draw them to democrats, some of his rhetoric
around immigration, Latinos more generally.
But democrats haven't necessarily done the
work and considered how diverse Latinos are
as a population, right? In florida. They're
very different than they are in texas for
instance. And so you don't have a real sort
of drilling down among democrats to figure
out how do you message to Latinos? It's not
just about immigration, it's about small business,
it's about education, it's about any number
of issues. And so I think you're gonna see
this trend continue, particularly as you said
with latino men in this cycle. And I think
republicans have also been smart to recruit
a lot of different, uh, people as their candidates.
Right. They have a very, very diverse pool
of candidates who are running, particularly
in the house and that again goes away in terms
of connecting different communities with their,
their parties. So this is a concern certainly
for democrats. And I think a boon, I think
we'll see for republicans going forward. And
I would add to that. I mean, this is actually
one of my, like my little pet issues that
I'm always thinking about because I think
it's one of the most fascinating political
stories that's unfolding. It's Nevada, Arizona
parts of texas florida, but in other places
like north Carolina, parts of pennsylvania,
Parts of states, I was just in Kansas. Latinos
are the second largest minority population
in the state of Kansas, they have a very competitive
gubernatorial race in that state. But there
was an interesting story that I just read
about the race in Arizona the gubernatorial
race there, Kari Lake versus Katie Hobbs.
And um in the story, they talk about how some
latino voters are certainly turned off by
Kerry Lake, the republicans right around immigration,
saying that there's an invasion that the border
is out of control. But some Latinos, including
some recent immigrants who themselves came
to the United States as immigrants or across
the border seeking asylum or what have you
were not at all turned off by by that for
whatever reason. And I do think that so much
of what we're seeing when it comes to um non
white groups, black voters, latino voters,
asian american voters is um, you know, the
political system needs to grapple with the
fact that some people, many people perhaps
are going to um their their racial and ethnic
identity are not going to be the number one
thing for them. It might be other things that
might be what they consider economics, but
it might also be things like religion, you
could have people um grouping themselves together,
identifying as evangelicals or or, you know,
other things that that um, that define who
they are and what matters to them. There's
also a lot now in this country, a lot of biracial
people, people whose racial identities in
their own minds are ambiguous. And I think
that some of that is really playing out. And
um, your I think it's confusing to people
sometimes when they say like, why would a
latino voter vote for a candidate who, you
know, maybe in your view demonizes immigrants.
They may not think of that. They may not think
that issue is a, that important to, to them.
And they, there may be differences within
groups, different immigrant groups, you know,
not identify mexicans, maybe not identifying
with Cubans and so on and so forth. It gets
complicated. But I think we're seeing that
in the aggregate in all of these different
places where, um, where voters are breaking
off from their group behavior of the past
and making different decisions. And I definitely
think we will see a lot of that in this cycle.
Um, Nevada is very competitive state now when
democrats have wanted in the last two election
cycles at the presidential level. And that's
largely because latino voters are very unhappy
about the economy. And, uh, that if you ask
a lot of democrats, they would say that should
not really be that much of a battleground
state. And it very much is, it may even be
more so at this point than Arizona, I think,
I think that's right. And so every is very
complicated Rachel as someone who has to plan
and assign and higher, um, And, and fight
fight the mistakes of journalism past, right?
The idea that, well, you're covering the Latino
population. So you're gonna spend most of
your time on the immigration issue um this
year and Trump 2020. I think me and abby both
are dead right. Just it's a lot more complicated
than that. Uh the constituency is a lot more
complicated. There's a lot a lot of diversity.
And so how do you how do you come at that
from who are we gonna hire, where we gonna
put them, what stories are we going to cover?
I think Abby set this up so well by saying
we can't make assumptions about the latino
electorate as a whole and well, there's an
interesting overall story to tell in the aggregate
about latino voters. We also have to understand
there are many rich storylines within that
and we can't make assumptions about the group
as a whole. When you say the mistakes of the
past, the media has tended to make some of
those mistakes. We have to be really careful
about understanding that mexican voters and
Cuban voters may feel very different and within
a group that people will feel very, very differently.
So we can't paint too broad a brush with any
group including with latino voters. So that's
something that we have to be very conscious
of. We have to make sure that in the stories
we tell and the places we go throughout the
country, we're keeping all of that in mind
and that we're really hearing from the voters
individually and letting them put it in their
words, we are not making assumptions about
what people feel. We are asking them what
they feel and we have wonderful reporters
like Avi and Nia out there doing those interviews
and collecting that information. So this one,
I'm gonna add a little bit to this question
because it's a very good one. And my ad is
going to be on where we are right now because
of early voting. Uh to get to the point about
volatility and to Rachel's point about we
get paid to follow facts, we don't get paid
to make assumptions. Do you think the uptick
in voter registration in Georgia will affect
the gubernatorial election? That's also close,
let's affect all elections. I'll add that.
And then the dynamic of early voting in the
sense that again, uh to abby abby just made
a very good point about Nevada democrats thought
it was shifting there. Well, maybe not right
now or maybe it's gonna slow, maybe it's not
gonna go as quickly as they think. Um you
know, the democrat, joe biden won Georgia
right? Despite what donald trump says, joe
biden won Georgia just narrowly. So, and then
in the runoff Georgia elected a black preacher
and a jewish man to the United States Senate.
If you had asked me 10 years ago, would Georgia
do that at the same, They do it at all. Never
mind at the same time. I would have said what,
you know, but but you know, so States are
changing, but political climate has always
changed. So we see these long lines for early
voting, if you take the 2020 model, you would
say advantage democrats, but we can't assume
you cannot definitely not in Georgia. We,
and, and really nowhere in the country, I
don't think that turnout in and of itself
tells us anything anymore because republicans
are turning out to I did happen to be on the
phone that someone who was in Georgia today,
very well connected person, a democrat who
um, who indicated to me, I mean in their precinct,
they went to vote early yesterday and it was
like the middle of the day, the lines were
crazy long. So there is clearly, you're seeing
the enthusiasm in the places where democrats
are, but I don't think you can rule out that
that enthusiasm is also there in the more
rural parts of the state and also that the
suburbs are up for grabs in Georgia. And um,
you can't really say for sure that if you
see, uh, like long voting lines in the suburbs
of Atlanta, how exactly that is going to play
out in this particular environment in which
I think suburban voters now because of the
economy and suburban women, white women in
particular are, you know, they're giving republicans
a second look. And I think that that's playing
out as we speak, as people are literally going
out to vote. You make a key question in presidential
years now, we almost never see ticket splitting
anymore, meaning you pick a party for president
and then you switch, you know, when you vote
for United States Senate, you do something
else used to be pretty common. It's non existent
in 2016 to 2020 I think it happened once or
twice. I think we'll see a lot of ticket splitting
this time. I was talking to a pollster today
who said she had a focus group where there
was a Stacey Abrams herschel walker voter
try to, you know, and she said that's exactly
what she said. She said, talk, keep telling
me so. I I just think you also have to remember,
you know, people have been through three years
of stress, right? The pandemic stress than
the economic stress, whatever personal issues,
they may have their own all right then, their
own political beliefs that I think surprises
and volatility are going to be the norm, which
is why I'll come to you with this question
here, does the political climate favors elden
in new york for governor, a Republican candidate
in a state that has been overwhelmingly blue.
But every now and then the republicans. That's
right. I mean, every now and then there's
a surprise, I was in a meeting yesterday with
some republicans, they started talking about
the House races there and they feel obviously
good about the House, but also just talking
about the gubernatorial race there and the
anxiety that a lot of new Yorkers have particularly
around crime. A lot of folks thought, okay,
eric Adam, former law enforcement guy, he
ran on crime ran on improving crime and it
looks like there's still a lot of anxiety
around crime in new york. So sure, I mean,
maybe this will be much more competitive than
than democrats thought it would be going in,
but there's just so many dynamics, you know,
anytime I'm on a panel, I have to remind myself
that we don't really know anything right.
We have these sort of anecdotal conversations.
We talked to strategists and sources and and
voters and we have polling as well, which,
you know, you know, pools great, you know,
there's a whole conversation to be had about,
about the reliability of polls now, but we
don't, yeah, we don't really know. So we'll
just have to wait to see where, you know,
where the voters go. But listen, I mean, if
if democrats are in trouble in new york, I
mean, they're going to be in trouble in all
sorts of places around the country. So we'll
just have to see. But when I was doing those
competitive house races earlier and I said,
pennsylvania will tell us early on, you know,
if Susan Wild can hold on and matt Cartwright
can hold on, Nia's point about new york, even
if Kathy huckle is winning the race for governor,
how close is it? If it's if it's way closer
than it has been in the past that tells you
something it tells you republicans are turning
out or it tells you independents are voting
more republican. Even sometimes the margins
matter, even if a race doesn't flip, you're
you're learning a lot about turnout, which
brings me to I think a giant question. Um,
and maybe the answer is a little different
now than it would have been in july or august,
but maybe it's not. And it just seems that
way. How big of a role do you think abortion
will play in the midterms? This vote? Does
the voter registration spike? We saw in Kansas
in particular seems to be happening elsewhere.
Rachel to you first on this one in terms of
stories that generate interest, right? You
know, you're right, we cover stories because
they're news. But you see the reaction in
the comments posted when the Supreme Court
wiped out roe v wade and made Dobbs the law
of the land and sent to every one of those
50 states. This is up to you now. A what did
we see in terms of news interest and be just
in terms of thinking, okay, this is a big
change in a political year. I had a plan.
I need a new one was a huge story. It was
at the time. It was a historic decision. Our
audiences are very smart and very engaged
and they always come when it's a big news
moment and and they have, you know, almost
100% accuracy and showing us when that big
news moment is happening. So we we saw audiences
very engaged, maybe a little less so on the
issue now than when it first started, which
is what, you know, we're seeing across the
country. Again, we just don't know, we have
a couple of anecdotal examples based on particular
stories, but this race has been so volatile
this year and it looked like abortion rights
would be the big driver, that it looked like
the economy and inflation would be the big
driver. Now, maybe it's crime as we were just
saying in new york. We know that certainly
do democrats and the president are really
leaning into the issue of abortion rights.
We know that with young voters and with certain
groups of voters, it will particularly resonate,
but we don't have a sense yet of how big a
driving issue it will turn out to be a few
months have passed. Democrats will probably
hoping to to go with that as an issue right
out of the gate. But now we're a few months
later, and it's just not clear anymore, joe
jump in on that point of view, let me throw
this question into the mix because I think
it asked the other the flip side, if you will,
do you think the Supreme Court decision will
have the same uh, increased voter turnout
for pro lifers as well as pro choicers, that
that's the question, right? Do do do anti
abortion voters say, oh we won I don't need
to vote, or do they say okay, we won by voting,
we got this because we voted and trump was
elected and appointed, all those judges. Now,
what? Yeah, I mean, I think that that is definitely
a possibility. The question is perhaps not
whether they will be inclined to turn out,
but whether it will be a greater effect than
people who want to protect abortion rights
again, sorry to say, but we don't really know.
Um I actually was, I mean, as I mentioned,
I was in Kansas about a week and a half ago
on this very topic, just to see, You know,
Kansas is the state where in August they had
a constitutional referendum on abortion that
basically asked voters do you want to keep
protections for abortion in our state constitution?
It surprised a lot of people when by 60% voters
said Yes, we do want to keep this constitutional
amendment, we don't want to get rid of it.
And um it raised a lot of questions about
whether or not the kind of turnout, it was
basically record or close to record turnout
for a primary in that state. There were no
other major races on the ballot. Um so people
were coming out for the referendum and um
the data suggests that women registered new
new women, younger women registered for the
first time. Uh there was even an uptick in
latino registration for that referendum in
Kansas. And um and in order for anything to
pass in Kansas, a lot of republicans have
to go along with it. And there were a lot
of moderate republicans who did not want to
change the state's constitution. So but that
all being said, I went down to Kansas, looked
at how the democrats were running. The democrat
for governor is running on the economy, She
is not running on abortion, she's not running
away from abortion, but she is not running
on abortion. And I think it it does tell you
that for democrats, abortion is a really important
tool in their toolbox to bring out their voters,
maybe to open up a conversation with some
voters who are moderate who are concerned
about the issue and are up for grabs, but
it's not going to be the issue that that for
most voters is going to decide how they cast
their ballot. And so they have to shore up
their economic messaging and cannot rely on
abortion. But but there's no question in my
mind that many democrats across the country,
um, in all kinds of different states, red
states, blue states, purple states what they're
seeing with moderate women, some of whom might
be registered as republican or independence
is that this issue does matter to them. They
do not want to see largely more stringent
abortion laws that might already exist where
they live. And so that is a way in with those
women who they who democrats in particular
need in order to win. And the pro the anti
abortion world is already fired up. They are
coming out to vote. And I think the polling
frankly just suggests that in terms of just
sheer numbers, there are just more americans
who generally support some degree of abortion
rights than the other way around. And the
question is, will they vote on that? And to
that point, I'm gonna bring this question.
Have you made the point about the moderate
women who might be republicans or it might
be independence or might be soft democrats
who are mad about inflation or disappointed?
For one reason or another about joe biden,
but how is the issue of abortion going to
affect swing states? I think that is the big
test. The philadelphia suburbs, the Atlanta
suburbs in these races for governor and Senate
doesn't matter in the place that decides,
You know, I think it doesn't, I think, you
know, obviously joe biden came out yesterday
or the day before and said if the democrats
keep control, they would obviously have to
not only keep control of the House but grow
their margins margins in the Senate that they
would want to codify roe v wade. They clearly
want to make this an issue part of it. I think
for France is that when you talk about abortion
and the GOP stands on abortion, they think
that the GOP stands on abortion is a signifier
for republicans being extremists in other
areas too. Right. So in that way they can
message this to the swing voters, college
educated white women in particular in some
of these suburban areas. And sort of the reality
is women get abortions, Men take women to
get abortions, Republicans get abortions,
democrats, independents get abortions. And
so I do think it'll be a motivating factor.
I think it was especially helpful for democrats
in the summer when there were stories about
abortions, uh, in the news, particularly there
was the 10 year old girl who was raped. Uh,
and this was in Ohio and she had to go to
indiana and get an abortion. Those sorts of
extreme stories. I think very much landed
with average average americans. Uh, and I
think led to some of the polling we saw about
abortion being a top issue. Those stories
in some ways faded. But you do see democrats
running on this in Bernie Sanders mind maybe
running on it a little bit too much and not
having the kind of economic message. But I
do think in these areas, these suburban, we
always talk about it whether they're soccer
moms or security moms or or however you want
to call them. But those are the true um, you
know, swing voters and they're gonna determine
these elections. Um, so let me bring up another
name. This is joe biden's first midterm, He's
the President of the States, but the other
guy is in the news. A fair amount to questions
about this Rachel to you first, in the sense
that you again, you make a plan and then the
news environment changes your plan. Um, I
knew trump was not gonna go away, but even
I'm a little surprised at how much she is
in the news. There's so in the diversity of
the news about him. But two questions how
is trump subpoena impacted the races and the
candidate he has endorsed. How do you think
trump's and the second one? How do you think
trump's influence will affect the upcoming
midterms? Uh, in terms of coverage and planning?
You know, we cover the news objectively to
the best we can. We're not perfect, but we
cover the news objectively, the best we can.
But in that process, you're making hundreds
of subjective decisions like what goes on
the front page of the website trump's been
nudging his way in a fair amount. That's fair
to say. We have these discussions really daily
about what is the right amount of coverage.
How do we frame the stories of even today,
there has been news, some, some of the news
is directly related to the campaign trail,
Some of it is related to lawsuits and depositions
and mar a Lago searches. So the news is coming
in a lot of different forms, some with a clear
direct effect and some, we just have no idea
whether there will be any effect. Certainly
the former president's involvement has changed
the shape of the race. We find ourselves writing
a lot about election deniers and people like
Kerry lake but it's also brought to the forefront
of the news, a group of people that we normally
don't pay so much attention to in midterm
elections. The secretaries of state, the Attorney
General, the officials who are protecting
voting in America and the threats that many
of them have undergone and what that looks
like and how you make sure the votes are counted
in the right way. This is something that in
past elections. Yes, we would talk a little
bit about but we've devoted much more attention
to secretaries of state than we have in years
past. So you see the the sometimes direct
effect of donald trump and then you see all
the ripple effects and the way that it affects
really the whole framing and coverage of the
race. And these are donald trump's candidates,
right? I mean, herschel walker J. D. Vance
tutor Dixon blake masters dr Oz. I mean these
are his handpicked candidates and to the extent
that republicans win or lose particularly
in the Senate, they're either going to credit
trump or blame trump because these are the
candidates that that he wanted to see, you
know what's striking to me though, just as
you were talking Rachel. I was just thinking
because I mean I was at the White House covering
trump when he was president and it felt like
a never ending series of investigations and
impeachments and roller and and now even when
he is not president, it's still a never ending
series of investigations and impeachments
and and like it's it's wild actually, I think
the degree to which trump is not just in the
news, but he's in the courts like he's in
these really complicated um ongoing long term
stories and I don't know, I mean Rachel you
may know better than I do. I actually wonder
sometimes how much the public is following
some of this stuff, the twists and turns and
the ins and outs that even I who pay attention
to this quite a lot lose track sometimes of
where things are headed and which FBI probe
is related to what and um I mean and and that's
not even counting the probes that involve
his social media company that he's maybe trying
to sell. And so there's a lot going on with
trump at all times. Much of it is very legal
and very in the leads and so if it feels like
we haven't like exited the trump era, it's
because we literally have not, you can't because
you can't you can't there are a lot of democrats,
they stop talking about him, you know, he's
planning to run for president again, he's
still the most influential person in the Republican
party, these stories of these issues. These
controversies are real, they're about real
things. This is not, you know, people magazine
trying to keep some celebrity, you know, in
the news past the prime, I'm not criticizing
people, it's not it's not it's not that kind
of journalism, it's it's it's legit. Do we
have conversations about the balance? Yes,
but well, I will say, I think People magazine
does a very nice job, but I think, you know,
to at this point it's the news of what happened.
But then we also spend a lot of time talking
about how do we do stories that actually help
audiences keep up? Because to your point there
is so much and it's complicated and there
are a lot of twists and turns, so are we stepping
back And connecting those dots for audiences?
So it doesn't feel like they're just being
hit with news in all directions, but that
we're really helping them navigate those different
stories and put all the pieces together. I
would make one other point because Rachel
and Neil touched on this, this is a you know,
you might say I have a little bit more gray
hair than everybody else up here. I've been
doing this for nearly 40 years and I've lived
through at my prior job at this job for 25
years. The conversation about media bias and
we can talk about that if you wish. Um but
I know where I work and I know that people
on this stage very well. We're not anti trump
or pro biden. We get criticized sometimes
for spending time on these stories, especially
the Secretary of State issue or the election
stuff. We have to be pro truth whether whether
any of you want to get into journalism or
government public service. Thank you. If you
do, thank you. If you do our institutions
are under attack. Math is under attack. Two
plus two is four. No matter who the President
United States is the person who gets the most
votes wins in a democracy that cannot change
that. That cannot change. And so we have to
repeatedly say that's not true. Sometimes
we have to say that's a lie when people who
know better keep saying things. Uh and it
puts, you know, we get criticized for it.
Uh I won't stop doing it because it's that's
what I do. I've been doing it for a long time
counting votes. Joe biden won donald trump
had every opportunity and took every opportunity
to ask for recounts where it was allowed.
He never ever be mad at any candidate who
does that. That's their right. We have systems
and rules for a reason. Ask for another one.
You know, do everything. You can go to court
70 times. All of them thrown out including
a bunch of Trump judges threw them out. And
so to say Joe Biden is the President. United
States is not controversial. It's a fact.
it's a fact to say he got more votes. It's
not controversial. The people who count votes,
democrats, republicans to county election
officials, they don't get paid much money.
Some of them are getting their lives threatens
now. So there is a threat to democracy and
fact and truth that I hope all of you, especially
young people, no matter what you get into,
no matter what your politics, please vote
if you're republican vote republican or democrat,
democrat, whatever you want to do. But but
remember that basic rules if we do not, I
have a process and a law and a whistle. If
there's not a whistle to end the game, the
game never ends and politics is not a game.
I'm just trying to use a sports metaphor.
I try to use it sometimes to break through
to some people who still think you know that
donald trump should be President of States
today, but if we don't have a process where
it's over. Al gore knew he lost at the Supreme
Court, he still thinks he got the most votes.
He still thinks he should be president should
have been president, United States but he
respected the process. Everything collapses
if we don't have that sorry for that but that
one gets under my skin a little bit. Um This
is a question you brought this up earlier.
So I'll start with you, polling was far from
accurate in 2016 to 2020. Um can polling be
seen as an accurate predictor of the outcome
of the midterms quibble with the question
just a little bit. Um polling was not grossly
inaccurate. If you think of polling as an
exact science, you know, joe biden was up
by 2.1 points and he won the state by 10 or
trump won the state by one. Therefore, that
poll is wrong. No, it's data data science
tells you there's a margin of error. We want
everything to be exact in our lives. There
were some places where the polling was off.
Um And Republican and Republican pollsters
especially, but all pollsters have identified
that some people who are told don't vote early
don't trust the media. There's there's a participation
question issue challenge for pollsters among
um I'll call them trump republicans but they're
not just trump republicans. But polling by
and large was pretty accurate if you accept
the margin of error, but it has become a source
of legitimate there. I think, I think there
are less, there's less public polling by media
organizations in the states now because they
think it's not worth it that they're just
gonna get hammered. Yeah, I think that's right.
And you know, I guess Nate Cohn had a story
of about this. I think it was last week, it's
increasingly hard to get people to participate
in polls right. I think he was saying something
like it takes a day to actually get somebody
um to get, you know, 24 hours, I should actually
get somebody to answer the phone and actually
respond to a pollster. Listen, I think given
what we've seen over these last years, there
is more skepticism around poles, hope hopefully
there is more uh informed look at polls and
people do look at them and and notice the
margin of error. I have to say that for me
as a journalist, I feel like we have moved
away a little bit more from polls. We used
to be much more polling centric, we would
have a, you know, a day or two, a polling
coverage after we would release a pole. And
uh, and you know, we got burned some of us
by relying too heavily on polls. CNN I think
it had a pool showing. Andrew gillum up by
like nine or 10 points in that florida governor's
race in 2018. We obviously all know how that
turned out. And I can say when I look at polls,
if I see a poll where someone is up by like
seven or eight points in like the Wisconsin
Senate race for instance. And like this is
like this is not real right? It's just not
really. I think, I think in some poll Warnock
is up over walker by like maybe six points
or four points. That also just seems unrealistic
Jaime Harrison down in south Carolina that
race that he was in for Senate, he was up
in samples. I'm from south Carolina. I never
believed any of those polls because it just
uh, seemed unlikely. So I think, listen, I
think we all are a bit more skeptical around
holes and we should be uh, they are, they
are meant to be predictive. They're meant
to be a snapshot in time time of a select
group of people who answered a phone from
a stranger and talk to them and gave them
their opinion about who they would vote for.
So I think we have learned as the public and
as well as the news media to look at polls
more skeptically used more wisely and how
we're covering the right, I mean, that has
changed a lot and we don't want to put too
much emphasis Nia's point on any one whole
because anyone poll can be misleading. So
if we're going to be in the space, at least
if we're showing an aggregate or giving audiences
a sense of these three polls that just came
out, here's what they seem to tell us at this
moment in time knowing that things might change
and it might be completely different in three
weeks anyway. And I think also really emphasizing
to our audience is the margin of error. If
the candidate is within the margin of error,
they are not ahead, they are within the margin
of error. And I think we we shorthanded that
a little too much in years past and we've
really worked to be more precise because we
need to lean into the limitations of the pole.
Yes, it's a tool that maybe it tells us a
little bit more than we knew before. Maybe
it doesn't. But either way it's a moment we're
explaining what we don't know or what the
limitations are is just as important as saying
what we think the numbers tell us at a given
moment in time. Look at the trajectory, not
the numbers, right? Is the president's approval
rating up compared to the last one or there
are three or four poles out there. One of
them might show six point swing 12111, but
in the same direction, look at trajectory.
Don't invest over all the numbers and we average
polls right? So don't, don't trust anyone.
It's a snapshot of that moment. Um, Alright,
here we go. Um, what are your thoughts on
the recent trend in republicans running far
right campaigns, but democrats having to moderate
themselves in order to keep the races competitive.
That's an interesting take. Um, Well, I think
I gather where the questions coming from.
I think it has a lot to do with, um, just
different objectives for the two parties.
I think one of the side effects of trump has
been that the theory of the case right now
for republicans by and large is that if you
turn, you know, they think if we turn our
people out and that's it. We're good, like
we'll, we'll we'll be fine, we'll we'll do
really well. So they're really running trying
to run a trump like campaign. Although I think
many of them find that there are limitations
to that because um, they're not trump so they
can't bring people out in the same way. I
think there are a lot of Republican candidates
who in some states do not feel like they need
to pivot to the center for a general election.
They're not, they're not aiming to do too
much persuasion on the belief that there are
enough republican and Republican leaning voters
that it would be enough for them. I think
like a carry lake is a good example of that,
it might be enough for her in a state like
Arizona. But um, if you're dr Oz in a state
like pennsylvania, that doesn't really work.
He's had to tack to the center because pennsylvania
is just not that kind of state democrats.
I think on the other hand, recognize that
they need their people, plus they need to
persuade some people in the middle. And um,
and so I think that they run their campaigns
based on that belief based on their version
of the math, but I mean just if you pay attention
to my language here, their version of the
math, Like the camp, these campaigns and these
um political parties, they kind of have to
decide when they go into these races, what
do they need to do? Do we need to persuade
people do we need to turn people out, do we
need to do a combination of the two? I think
republicans largely in, in this country right
now, um are very much in the turnout. Are
people Theory of the case for because of Trump
um Democrats can't be of that mind set because
they know that they have to win over independence.
They saw what happened with Hillary Clinton
in 2016. Um and so they're operating on those
assumptions and we will see who turns out
to be right. It will work for republicans
in some places and it won't work for them
in other places. I think it's very state by
state, in some cases, very district by district,
how that will turn out. Um But one part of
it also is that the average Republican Congress
person in this country is running in a deep
red district. They are not running in any
way, shape or form where they have to convince
people somewhere in the political middle.
So that's part of the reason why you're seeing
that, is that generally, um you know, the
result of redistricting has been that republicans
have had a wide swath of the country to draw
districts in and they've drawn those districts
to their great advantage and that means that
most of their candidates don't have to talk
to the middle. It's different when you get
to the Senate, it's different when you get
two gubernatorial races. But that's that's
probably why you're seeing that on the rip.
And I think the problem that democrats have
particularly midterms is they are relying
on voters who don't show up at the rate in
mid terms that they show up in presidential
elections. So democrats need young voters
to turn out in a great margin. They sort of
don't turn up at the same rate. Republicans
are relying on old, reliable voters and I
mean old voters really. Um and and so I think
democrats have to, you know, kind of tailor
their message much more so than republicans
because of their voters just aren't as reliable
in midterm elections. And yet, back to the
planning part. This, this raises to me one
of the fascinating questions about this midterm
election cycle, because we saw a very high,
high relatively historically. I think american
voter participation is actually pathetic,
and I wish it would be much higher than it
is. Everybody should vote. Everybody should
vote, everybody is eligible to vote, should
vote. But we did see relatively increased
turnout in 2016 than a 2018 midterm election.
That turnout was also considerably higher.
A lot of that was democrats coming up because
they were mad at trump, but republican turnout
was not terrible in 2018. Then you had 2020
which trump, got more votes in 2020 did in
2016. And he still lost the popular vote by
a larger margin because more democrats came
out. But pennsylvania is my laboratory for
that. That trump voters came out of the woodwork
in that state and he still lost it. Um And
so that's that's one of the questions from
a planning perspective. When you see this
early voting. When you do see someone asked
the question earlier, we did we know that
right after dobbs registration of women, people
in the suburbs did go up. Did go up. Has that
been sustained all the way through? That's
one of the unpredictable in terms of the planet
do we live in an age of higher participation?
I still don't think it's high enough, but
higher participation or do we get a traditional
midterm where it drops off particularly among
the democratic constituent? If it drops off,
then republicans will take the house, republicans
will probably take the senate and republicans
will win more of the governor's races. If
it's up again, We got a long week. Right?
And this is something, I mean, it looks like
early, early days, early signs, it looks like
what from what we're seeing in these initial
numbers, that the electorate is engaged, that
we're seeing similar numbers to 2018 and maybe
not 2020 because it's a presidential election
year, but to the 2018 cycle, the question
is, will that hold, what will it look like
a few weeks from now. We don't know what the
effects of the pandemic will be in the way
that that has changed voting. That is a major
issue in the presidential election and the
mail in ballots. Are people going to revert
back to older habits? Has covid permanently
changed the way people vote and how they show
up. So that's a question and a storyline we
need to follow. It's the voting itself. It's
how they vote. It's when they vote and and
these all questions and of course where the
voters are coming from and john this is something
that you do so well. And I always admire this
when you're explaining the magic well on election
night, looking at where are the votes coming
in and what do we know so far? And it might
look like things are moving red but we don't
have these votes from these key cities. And
I think that will be particularly important
as we get to election night because we don't
know where that will end up. And something
might look very different early on in the
night or at midnight then it looks at three
a.m. To that point we're going to have a very
similar election night here than 2020 it could
be a runoff in Georgia on december 6th month.
So a month later, if if that candidate actually
50% plus one in Georgia. So it's possible
we have a runoff there, but also to Rachel's
point if you remember election night 2020
donald trump was winning in some states that
we knew were going to turn blue and he was
ahead leading in states that ended up turning
blue pennsylvania Georgia and Arizona among
them. And at one point joe biden was leading
in Ohio, he was leading in texas and he was
leading in another red state. And you democrats
are texting like florida florida florida.
It's like oh my some states count election
Day ballots first. Some states count the mail
in early voting mail in or early voting cast
ballots first and that because democrats voted
so disproportionately early in 2020 and republicans
voted on Election Day disproportionately in
2020 that's what happened in the end. They
counted all the votes and we got to the facts.
But this is part of the republican conspiracy
theory that you know, they brought in votes
in Detroit and they brought in votes in pennsylvania
and they flipped it. No, it's just the way
that state kind of the in a certain order
and other states count them in a different
order. You don't hear joe biden saying I want
Ohio and texas and florida because they understand
how the process works. But it's complicated
because states decide how to do it. Each state
does in its own way. It can be very interesting.
This is a great question, especially because
there was an interview in Punch bowl today
by leader McCarthy who could be speaker McCarthy
about republican agenda priorities. And I
had, I was thinking about it all day, really
are democrats, you know, taking advantage
of trying to frame things in a way that sometimes
they get opportunities from in these interviews
with democratic candidates struggle in elections
due to a poorly performing economy and a propensity
to blame the president and by extension his
party, How will democrats defend their economic
positions and what solutions can they put
forward? A part of it is their solutions?
Part of it is midterms are normally a referendum
on the president, the guy in power, can you
make it a choice? Can you say you're mad at
me? But these guys will do that? Yeah, I mean,
I I similarly john we were on the same page
today, I was thinking about Leader McCarthy
today too, and um and also just thinking about
like, we really don't know what republicans
are going to do if they're in power and the
voters should probably know that so that they
can make a decision about what they want.
Um It is interesting, I mean, I think you've
seen the democrats trying to do this choice
thing by talking about, you know, senator
rick scott's plan that he had put out some
months ago. Um the way democrats describe
it, he would basically put um Entitlements
up for a vote every five years. Um he would
implement and actually this is what the plan
says, he would implement a pretty regressive
tax um for like lower income people. Uh and
so democrats are trying to run on that, I
have to say, I don't really think that is
sticking very much. I don't think most voters
know we're talking about when we say Senator
scott's plan, but it just encounter it encapsulates
how hard it is when you are the party in power
and it's just very easy for people to cast
blame uh than to give you credit for things
that a you haven't done or be that maybe you
have done, but they don't feel the impact
of it. And so it is just a difficult thing
that they are trying to do. Um but I mean
just from our perspective as journalists,
I mean, my thought today was this interview
in Punch Bowl, that Leader McCarthy did and
other reporting that's out there, there is
a kind of need to empower voters with an actual
understanding of what the parties are actually
going to do, like what are republicans actually
running on, um in terms of how they are going
to lead. And I think that in the next few
weeks is going to become, I think it needs
to be part of the story of getting into the
midterms here to help empower voters. We have
hit the clock here, I'm gonna use the authority
invested in me by absolutely nobody to extend
this to extend it, just a minute or two to
give each of my colleagues just a chance and
if I didn't get your question, I'm sorry,
I tried to get as many questions as I could
in the We have, because they're all fantastic
and thank you for them. Even if we didn't
get to your questions, um just give each of
my colleagues Rachel, just come around in
order just a chance. Just closing statement
of your choice about about your job, about
any message to the young people here about
a surprise in this year. Take 30, seconds,
say whatever you wish, the floor is yours,
senator. I love elections and election coverage.
It's it's one of the most important and exciting
things that we do, and especially to get to
do it at CNN with such amazing and talented
colleagues, where I learned so much every
time I listen to them, it's a really important
moment also to remember that we don't know,
we shouldn't predict because we're not good
at that. And all we can do really is help
our audiences understand how things might
play out, not in the way of speculating what
will happen, but just to point out here are
some factors we're looking at, here's what
we're watching for, here's how this might
come in, and that's the best guidance I think
we can give to audiences to explain what we're
paying attention to, and also what we don't
know. That might change the outcome because
for everything we say, 10, 12, 20, 100 factors
could change where we think we are at that
moment and so we really think of this as presenting
a guide. It is, this is a, this is a public
service and it's a responsibility that take
very, very seriously to try to provide the
best possible information we can to audiences
so that the voters can make their decision
whatever that decision might be and it's a
privilege to get to do that work. And I also
love elections mostly because it brings an
end to the speculation most of the time and
I think that that's good for all of us. I
just want to say that, I mean this year, look,
the turnout so far seems to be indicating
that people think this is a very important
election and it is and it is going to be an
incredibly consequential election and it might
take a little while, I'm just gonna tell you
that because Um transparency is important
like this may not be probably will not be
done on the first night because of the dynamics
that John was just talking about. But one
thing that I can tell you that I'm very proud
of how we handle this in 2020 at CNN we will
be transparent with you about what is going
on about why you're seeing what you're seeing
about um what we are expecting to have in
terms of what, what is coming to us in terms
of votes and so hopefully you guys will be
watching. Um, but, but that's I think what
we will try to give you is not any easy answers.
Not quick fixes, no predictions on election
night, but just some transparency about what's
going on as we wait for the voters to decide
because ultimately, uh, that's all there Is
to it. It might take a day or two or three,
but we will get an answer at the end of the
day and throughout that process. I think what
we do really well at CNN is not treat uh,
the, it's like a little bit of sausage making,
but it's actually central to the story in
this cycle, just like it was in 2020 and we
will make sure that you have the information
that you need in a way that you can digest
it so that you can understand what's going
on. Yeah. And I would say listen, we love
your viewership and we're so glad you came
out tonight. And I think for me, I would encourage
everybody to talk to as many people as you
can uh, to learn about the issues and how
people are feeling about the issues. We are
obviously experts and we read polls and we
talked to sources all the time. But often
times you can learn a lot about how people
are feeling in the country by talking to the
person who brings you up at target or talking
to your Uber driver. Talking to the woman
who collects your, your garbage. Uh, that's
how I've learned about the country. That's
how I learned about how actually people are
feeling about the direction of the country.
So that's what I would say. Listen. We obviously
love your viewership and we hope you watch
on election night. We'll all be there. Amen.
Uh, thank thank you all for coming. Thank
you for the smart questions. And I should
have said at the beginning, thanks for those
of you watching out there on the interweb
in the stream burst. Thank you. Thank you
for your time and attention as well and your
interest um, to the students. I would just
say we need you. Whatever you decide to do
when you get out of here. Uh, it's a cynical
time in America in many ways. It's a volatile
time in America economically culturally and
so on and so forth. It's easy to say. It doesn't
matter. We need you, we need you and we need
your fresh ideas. We need your interest in
technology. You're the generation that is
just naturally, so much more tolerant and
open minded, uh, than the generations that
came before you. Uh, keep that. Keep that
vote. No matter what your politics, please
vote. The last thing I'll say is I want to
thank my patient's son does not, he's not
a college prodigy here. Uh, Jonah King, My
11 year old, I wanted to come participate
and listen tonight and I appreciate his patients
there in the front row. His mom, by the way,
is the fabulous dana bash an alumni of this
great university. Um, so thank you son and
thank you all for coming. Thank you all for
coming.